parce qu'il est très important dans
l'action de pouvoir raconter une
histoire et les actions dans les films
rares lourdes vous pourrez prendre une
action et la mettre dans une autre scène
et vous ne verrez même pas la différence
moi je voulais faire comme un balai je
voulais une action qui soit belle à
regarder aussi qu'elle soit très bas
voire l'histoire est vraiment dans ce
film on n'avait pas le budget dans le
grand film
quand on n'a pas d'argent il faut
réfléchir un peu plus et travailler plus
dur vous êtes en concurrence avec des
personnes qui ont des centaines de
millions de dollars
watchers est ce que vous avez vu en fait
c'est comme ça que ça s'est passé c'est
à vous de juger parce que c'est vraiment
moi bonne année je suis heureux que vous
n'aviez pas regarder comment j'ai
commencé durant le premier mois de mon
entraînement parce que ce n'était pas
comme ça du tout ça c'est au bout de six
mois je crois que ce que m'a dit c'est
vraiment ça c'est quelque chose que j'ai
que j'ai découvert par moi même vu oui
les entraîneurs sont des athlètes
extraordinaires mais ils comprennent
aussi les lillois n'est ce pas de
l'histoire et que l'action la danse la
chanson tout est une histoire c'est
comme ça que vous vous atteignez votre
public
le premier jour de répétition c'est a
dit j'ai une idée des phases i et il a
commencé à ses ailiers comme ça je me
suis dit bah non c'est pas possible
c'est effrayant parce que l'a fait il ya
une interview avec le président syrien
et puis là il a ce cheveu sur la langue
et je me suis confié pas vrai on ne peut
pas on peut pas rire de quelqu'un qui
acheminent sur l'instant mais vraiment
sa tasse et des arabes et de quelque
chose de très intéressant il a dit il
l'avait il avait en fait été bloqués il
avait un cheveu sur la langue
en vrai alors j'ai dit d'accord je ne
peux rien j'ai plus rien il s'est dit
que avec ce personnage il a fait plus
d'argent que que dieu il va tellement de
de puissance qu'est ce qui le rendrait
complètement dingue
il a identifié un problème je n'en
compte pas du tout convaincu qu'on
raconte il est même prêt solution qu'il
a quitté la prison
alors il s'est dit qu'est ce que je peux
avoir comme faiblesse que les gens
puissent vraiment se moquer de lui et ce
serait une raison pour eux pour laquelle
il serait devenu fou et en fait sam
jackson
croyez-moi quand vous quand il vous dit
qu'il a une idée c'est vraiment dur de
le dissuader
je crois que j'avais un peu oublié ce
rêve quand j'avais 12 ans histoire et
c'est vraiment bien ce petit garçon de
12 ans et a fait de moi ce fantasme mais
j'avais de là où ça vient je ne vais pas
vraiment essayé de faire l'analyse et
psychologique de ma fille il me semble
vraiment qu'il sait vraiment comment ils
peuvent me parler aux jeunes il ya un
élément là ya quelque chose de très
puissant quand on peut mélanger la
sophistication et d'efficacité technique
mineur et un oeil trees très aigu
cinématographiquement parlant avec un
enfant de 10 ans tout ça mélangé
c'est ma fille parce que matthew a un
instinct extraordinaire de deviner ce
que la personne en face a envie de voir
trois fils dont je me souviens je sais
où j'étais où j'étais assise et l'a16 et
la réaction des du public
c'est là où je tombé amoureux amoureux
des jeunes strauss indiana jones
l'espion qui m'aimait beaucoup c'est un
petit garçon fava aurait annoncé à tout
ce que j'avais vu sans offenser des gens
s'étaient elles mené la jeunesse ou
d'ivoire je ne veux plus voir de films
disney voilà le genre de film que je me
voir
voilà ici que je vois c'est ce que vous
voyez à l'écran quand un acteur arrive
que ce soit joli joli ce nom c'est quand
même ses gains quand ils arrivent ils
sont brillants ils se parlent pas ils
prennent le mieux c'est la feuille il
faut vendre trop idiot on ne pas être
vraiment impressionné et moi j'ai
suffisamment de chances qu'on veut dire
là je me dis oui parce qu'il sait on
vraiment beaucoup de talent c'est ses
collègues n'avaient pas de feeling et
son son rôle et je mourrai je me serais
dit ben oui c'est lui c'est lui pour le
rôle je compte il faut être courageux et
aussi donner la chance à nos jeunes
je peux dire
chose il ya une règle comme mon
grand-père marine un vrai rend toujours
l'autre personne très à l'aise c'est la
seule règle à laquelle je pense
j'ai rencontré mathieu il n'avait pas
terminé le script qui ne veut rien à me
montrer à part à par la banda si oui il
m'a pas donné un peu une vie général il
m'a prévenu vraiment de la douleur donc
si si si je faisais le film j'ai bien dû
avant de démarrer le tournage chambre et
j'ai pris la bande dessinée et j'ai
adoré et je me suis dit mais pourquoi ce
que je ne mets pas de bande dessinée je
lis toujours des délits vent prétentieux
je prends aucun plaisir mais c'est
surtout ce que j'ai envie de lire en
fête
pour moi le meilleur c'était de regarder
collèges relevant le défi de devenir
dans l'affabulation
c'est vraiment j'étais un parieur
j'aurais dit que l'eau salée ils
allaient complètement échoué
je le dis en tout entend tout respect
parce que moi j'aurais été incapable de
le faire je les fais donc je suis très
fier de cela
comme tout le monde le dit et c'est le
jeune homme là bas ils ne pouvaient ils
n'ont jamais imaginé all n ont pas assez
ça c'est vraiment un accomplissement